okay big headlines about job saver
Donald
fiat-chrysler the latest in the list in
the United States Trump is saying look
at the jobs that Trump is creating or
saving or preventing from leaving to
Mexico or whatever it turns out that
once again Donald Trump had nothing to
do with new jobs that fiat-chrysler will
be creating in the United States but
before we get into that let me remind
you of how this is now becoming a
ongoing trend carrier the big company
manufacturing company in the US that
does mostly the big air conditioners
although I'm not saying that that's all
they do but they're known for the big
air conditioning devices Donald Trump
cheered brag that he got a carrier to
keep 1,000 jobs in the United States now
how did he do that well number one
carrier was planning on moving 2,000
jobs out of the United States Trump got
them to keep a thousand a thousand are
still moving out of the US and Trump
said in exchange for this he would give
them millions of dollars in tax
incentives and also go a little lighter
on those thirty five percent tariffs he
had been talking about campaigning about
for companies that move jobs overseas
now remember that this is not economic
policy you can't just go to any company
that recognizes that the business
environment is just better elsewhere and
give them millions of dollars that's not
economic policy that's called crony
capitalism that's called legal bribes
etc and what completely blew up in
Trump's face about the carrier deal was
that when the CEO of United Technologies
Greg Hayes was interviewed about the
entire thing he said oh we're gonna take
a bunch of the money that Trump and
pence are giving us and we're going to
replace employees in the US with robots
so it's actually a deal that Trump made
I would be telling no one about this
deal because it's a deal that will over
the long term lead to jobs being
destroyed then Ford Motor Company Ford
said oh you know we're actually instead
of moving a building a factory moving
jobs rather to Mexico we're going to put
money into our existing American factory
and create some jobs here and of course
Trump bragging Trump is bragging
everybody bragging and then the Ford CEO
went on CNBC and said you know this has
nothing to do with
Trump whatsoever the reality is demand
is lower for some of our cars and we
realized we don't actually need as big
of a factory as we were what we were
going to put in Mexico so we're gonna do
a smaller expansion in the US Trump
bragging about the fact that business is
just not that great for Ford so they
have to create fewer jobs here than more
jobs in Mexico okay that's the
background now Fiat the car manufacturer
announced its plan to spend a billion
dollars in Ohio and Michigan they will
create 2,000 more jobs in the country
Trump tweets about it implying that this
is all sort of part of the great
business environment that Trump is
developing let's take a look at Trump's
two-part tweet quote it's finally
happening fiat-chrysler just announced
plans to invest 1 billion in Michigan
and Ohio plans adding 2,000 jobs this
after Ford said last week that it will
expand in Michigan in the US instead of
building a billion-dollar plant in
Mexico Thank You Ford and Fiat Chrysler
exclamation point because this is very
very exciting unfortunately yet another
news release from Fiat tells us that
it's all just smoke and mirrors from
Donald Trump this is a decision that
Fiat made in 2015 this has nothing to do
with Donald Trump whatsoever the the the
spokeswoman for Fiat was asked about
Fiats chief executive Sergio Marchionne
II and whether he had any communication
with Trump or the administration at all
the answer there is no when asked
whether Trump and his politics and the
business environment that's predicted to
exist under Trump had any effect on
Fiats decision the answer was no it did
not the reality is Trump had nothing to
do with this yeah I'm not sure he's even
taking credit in the same way that he
did in the Ford and carrier deals it
seems like it's like this correlation
doesn't equal causation type of thing
yeah but still the relating it to Ford
he took credit for Ford the constant
talking about just all these jobs that
manufacturing is creating the reality is
that so far we've heard three stories
maybe
we kind of heard about the Ford story
twice in two different ways but let's
call them three stories carrier Ford and
Fiat number one Trump isn't responsible
for any of them unless you think just
giving people money which is not
economic policy is is a way to actually
keep jobs in a way you want to brag
about and we later learn that some of
those decisions will either immediately
or in the longer term due to automation
or lower demand actually lead to fewer
jobs but that doesn't stop the Trump
sycophants from going around and trying
to get participation trophies for things
that Trump had nothing to do with the
reality is we've got our work cut out
for us during the next four years
because I've been getting emails Rachel
from Trump supporters they are convinced
that Trump is responsible for all these
jobs and there's no article I can link
them to that will convince them
otherwise because they've already been
primed by Trump to think it's all fake
news anything that doesn't coincide with
Trump is fake news it's going to be a
real uphill battle over the next four
years to deal with the trumpets well I
guess I worried how this is going to
falsely change their falsely change the
perception of him too positive then
further influence people's voting
decisions and they'll just have to wait
until concrete data comes out to prove
them otherwise but how long do we have
to wait for that oh I don't think the
concrete data will matter I mean just
think about it if we think about
something like unemployment right we had
unemployment measured in the same way
during Clinton during Bush wondering
Clinton during Bush - under President
Obama all of a sudden the unemployment
data that we talked about under Obama
oh well Obama's messing with the Bureau
of Labor Statistics they're talking
about the u3 when they should talk about
the youth the u6 even if the data pat
supports whatever case goes against
Donald Trump the trumpet's will just say
it's either fake news or the data has
been doctored it doesn't matter to them
and even if he was able to save or
create these thousands of jobs those
dwarfed in comparison to the millions of
jobs that Obama created during his
tenure in office yeah we mentioned that
yesterday 75 straight months of creating
you know over 11 million jobs I think
the number was by President Obama
so as I've told you before fact-checking
isn't going to solve the problem it's
that people are fact-checking but as we
saw during the campaign fact-checking
does not prevent Donald Trump from doing
anything and part of it is we've got to
continue to grow progressive media
independent media we've got a campaign
going at david pakman.com slash donate
which ends on at midnight on the day
donald trump is inaugurated i know it's
going to be a very very sad day for for
a lot of people it's gonna be a very
scary day for a lot of people but it may
also bring good news on january 21st we
do have this campaign i encourage you to
check it out
at david pakman.com slash donate send me
your thoughts about this i'm on twitter
at D Pakman back after this today's show
is brought to you by go daddy where you
can buy your own domain name build a
website or use any of Go Daddy's
business tools you can save 30 percent
at Tri godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show website for many
many many years the 24/7 customer
support has been a very good thing for
us I've called them at really odd times
when we've had website issues and they
are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
site over to GoDaddy they can do it all
thirteen million customers try it and
get 30% off at try go daddy.com slash
David